[Music]
let's use the time if anybody has any
questions uh I'm sure many of the 911
family members would be happy to take
questions yes question is why has this
territory around Ground Zero not been
declared a a historic preservation
district and why haven't covenants for
obvious reason being created where the
uh National Park Service would take over
zoning room the uh City landmarks
preservation commission is appointed by
the administration of the city of New
York Mayor Bloomberg appoints every
single person on that commission they
held public hearings several 911
families testified people who are here
rosalene Talon myself many other people
testify we were speaking to deaf ears
political correctness is what determined
that this area was not sacred ground as
far as the National Park Service the
family members who have labored since
shortly after 911 to declare Ground Zero
a national landmark and to have the a
Park Service take it over the answer The
Unofficial answer from the park service
is that they don't want to touch this
issue issue with the 10 foot pole it is
it's it's so it's so disheartening and
finally and I know you you want to uh
make a comment finally the name of this
so-called Memorial and museum is the
national 911 memorial and museum that is
a Lie the National Park Service has
nothing to do with it it is a name that
was made up by the people that control
the city of New York and Ground Zero
That's the basis that they're asking
people like you good-hearted people to
give in money to this it's a fraud it is
it is not a memorial in museum it's two
pools of
water it there's a museum it's seven
stories under the ground it's it's you
will it's not a museum that has anything
to do with our loved ones there's a
picture there that's it if you want to
know how old my son is go to a kiosk and
look it up on a computer if you want to
know if he was where he worked look at
the kiosk if you want to know if he was
a firefighter look in the kiosk it is a
disgrace it's a National Disgrace this
has to be made
public the family members who are here
we will never enter that building it is
dangerous and dishonorable to make the
families of the victims go 70 ft seven
stories underground one way in one way
out oh my God and and finally they are
taking 16,000 human remains that are now
in an area in Manhattan near the medical
examiner's office they're in
refrigerated trailers they're bringing
them down there for one reason they're
turning it into a ripes believe it or
not so good-hearted people like you will
pay $25 ahead to get in there to look at
a wall that says Behind These wall
there's
16,000 uh uh human remains and finally
no information about the dead these
heroic beautiful patriotics Americans
but the people who run the 9/11 Memorial
Museum are going to have a wall that we
call the terrorist Wall of Fame with the
pictures of the terrorists and their
their last statements and all of their
motivation that's the God's honest truth
but they have succeeded in suppressing
all the atrocities about this Memorial
Museum and Daisy Khan is on the board
yes Daisy KH is on the board and I'll
tell you one other thing before some
people were successful in having her
name removed she she had a space on the
Memorial website called Muslim voices
people were supposed to write in their
experience if they were a Muslim after
9/11 if they had a bad experience if
they had a good
experience and a copy of all of these
experiences was to be copied to another
Muslim group so that they could keep it
for their records you know what this is
an atrossity we need your help to stop
this this is about our loved ones this
is not about anybody's religion